Okay, so good morning. We are discussing
the American Revolution today.
So to review what we've done so far,
after the defeat of Napoleon um in 1815,
there are now four major civilizations
that are competing against each other
for world domination.
Um last class we did the British.
Today we will do the Americans. Next
week we'll do the Russians and the
Germans.
Okay.
So the Americans. When you think of
America, there's a very famous quote
from Oscar Wilde, who is a uh English
playwright, novelist, humorist. And he
said,
"America is the only country that went
from barbarism to decadence without
civilization in between."
Okay, so um he meant this as a joke. So
what did he mean by this? This is a
question we will discuss today.
And what I will show you is that America
in many ways, it was designed as the
anti-civilization.
The founding fathers of America
recognized the failings and problems of
civilization and designed a new form of
government based on enlightenment
principles in order to redeem humanity
from the prejudices
um the atrocities of civilization, okay?
So that's the argument we will look at
today.
All right. So um
the history of Americas
uh begins when the Europeans, led by the
Spanish, start to interact with the new
world. So the Spanish starting in 1492,
they will come and conquer the Aztecs,
the Mayans, and the Incas. And they will
establish basically
plantation economies where the Spanish
are extracting resources, primarily
gold, silver, uh from the
Americas. They will also establish sugar
plantations
on the islands of the Caribbean, and
they will man it with slaves from
Africa as well as other places.
And this is extremely profitable for the
Spanish. So, of course, the English, the
French, and the Dutch Republic, they
want to get they want to
get in on the action, okay? And at
first, they start to smuggle um
resources into the New World,
and they engage in piracy. In 1588,
the English navy defeats the Spar-
Spanish Armada. And this opens up the
New World now for the Europeans to come
and colonize it, okay? The problem,
though, is the Spanish control the best
parts of the New World.
And so, everyone else is stuck with
North America.
And in North America, there's a few
quite a few problems. First of all, the
weather's very cold.
Okay? So, it's not
um hospitable to colonization. Second
problem is that you have lots of Native
Americans in North America who are
extremely violent. They are used to
freedom, and they will fight to the
death.
Um at this time in history, the tallest,
strongest people in the world are
actually the Native Americans in North
America. Um also, you have lots of
diseases that are problematic for the
Europeans. So, um
the Europeans spent a lot of time,
basically decades, in trying to figure
out how to best colonize North America.
Um, so there were three major nations
that were trying to colonize North
America. You have the French, and what
they will do is they will establish the
fur trade in Canada and in the
Midwestern
United States. They will basically trade
with the natives
to bring fur back to Europe. And this is
a great deal for both the natives and
the French.
Uh, the Dutch come in and they will
establish colonies, uh, called New
Amsterdam. This is today New York City.
All right, so the Dutch tried to
establish colonies as well. The people
who are most successful at establishing
colonies are, uh, the British. And a lot
of it is because it is a very
grassroots, very bottom-up movement. So
the first major
colony for the British is Jamestown,
named after, um,
James I
of Britain.
And this is not a very successful
colony at first, but they persist. The
most successful colony is actually
Boston. What makes Boston unique at this
stage in North American history is that
it is established by a
company, the Massach- Massachusetts Bay
Colony that has a that has a charter
from the English Crown. Also, they bring
in families
into this area. So, um, before it was
basically men who came over, now it's
families who come over.
Um, and then third of all, the people
who come over are Puritans.
Puritans, um, as we discussed
previously, they believe in the
importance of literacy. Everyone has
responsibility to read the Bible in
order to interpret, um, the the command
of God properly. And so Boston,
from the very beginning, it's a literate
society. It has schools, it has
newspapers, um, it is very political and
it grows very very fast. Also, if you
look at Boston, it is perfectly situated
between North America and England. And
as England is industrializing, it
requires raw resources, mainly
agricultural products from this area,
okay? So, Boston grows rapidly because
of all these factors.
Um so, in
the year 1682, you can see that the
eastern United States has been colonized
by the British, okay? The French are
still in
Canada and they're going to move down to
the Midwest United States. The Spanish
are in the southern United States, this
is Florida. They found a colony called
St. Augustine. They will also in
California start to
build colonies as well. But as you can
see, the most of the economic activity
in North America is based on the eastern
seaboard. Now,
what's really important for us to
remember is the diversity of these
colonies. First of all, you have
differences in the in the economy. The
northern part will focus mostly on
mercantile trade. The southern part will
focus mostly on agriculture. To support
the agriculture, they will import slaves
from Africa
in order to
provide the labor for Charleston and
other places.
Also,
the motivations of the individuals are
different. So, some come for economic
reasons, but a lot come for religious
purposes. So, for example, there's a man
named William Penn. And he's a Quaker.
He believes in creating a peaceful
civilization. So, he has a charter from
the king and he creates he founds a new
colony called Pennsylvania, named after
him, that believes in religious and
national tolerance. So, a lot of Germans
come over and settle down in
Pennsylvania. The capital is
Philadelphia. And they are Quakers, so
they believe they must not fight against
others, okay? And this experiment
persists for decades, okay? It's It's
It's a pretty successful experiment, but
over time they come to conflict with the
natives and with other civilizations,
with other colonies, and as such they
start to take up arms, okay? Um
there's another colony called Baltimore.
It was founded actually as a Catholic uh
haven, okay? So, England at this point,
it is mainly Protestant or Puritan or
Anglican,
um and then Lord Baltimore decides to in
Maryland found a new colony that that
preaches religious tolerance, especially
for Catholics, okay? So, what's really
important for us to remember is that
even at this early stage in American
history, um
there's tremendous diversity, openness,
and religious tolerance in uh America,
okay? Does Does that make sense? All
right.
So, um
by the year
fifth 1750,
there are about a million British on the
eastern seaboard. That's a lot of
people, okay? In comparison, the French,
who who occupy actually most of the
territory in North America, there's only
40,000. Eventually, these two groups,
the British and the French, will come to
conflict creating something called the
French and Indian Wars.
Okay? And as you can see, it's not
really
it's really not a fair fight, okay?
You've got a million British versus
40,000 French. The Indians will get
involved as well because what's
happening is the these these colonies
are practicing a rapid form of
colonization and expansion. What they do
is they bring in immigrants, then um as
the population
uh
uh explodes, these immigrants will be
forced to move out west to settle
territory in the western,
uh, frontier of the
of these colonies. But, as as you know,
these these areas are, uh, inhabited by
Native Americans. And so, this
brings the Indians into conflict with
the British as well.
So, um, the resolution to this is that
King George III will proclaim
that the American colonies are not
allowed to move westwards of the
Appalachian Mountains, okay? So, he's
restricting the growth of,
um, the American colonies
in order to maintain friendship with the
natives.
And obviously, the Americans don't like
that. So, in 1764,
there are three major issues that bring
the American colonists into conflict
with the English Crown, okay? The first
is, as I just mentioned, the English
Crown is limiting the expansion of the
colonies westwards.
And they don't like that, okay?
Second, um, is that
it's a very ex- it was very expensive
for the British to protect the colonies
against the French and the Indians. In
fact, at this stage in history, it is
the British people, not the American
people, that are paying for the defense
of these colonies. In fact, the British
people pay 50 times more in taxes than
the Americans. And obviously, the the
uh, British people don't actually think
this is a fair deal.
All right? So, uh, the British Crown
tries in many instances to impose a tax
in order to in order to get Americans to
pay for the defense of their territory.
And Americans don't like that.
Uh, for the longest time, because of the
English Civil War and other factors, the
English Crown could not actually
interfere in uh North American affairs,
and so they were used to a high level of
autonomy. Okay? And the third major
problem between the colonists and the
British is in trade. So, at this stage
in history, all these nations, Spain,
France, Britain, they're practicing a
economic policy called mercantilism.
Okay? Mercantilism is the idea that all
trade should be directed by the state
for the purpose
of generating wealth for the state. And
so, what this means is that there are
different trade zones that are
established in competition with each
other. And so, if you are a British
subject, you're only allowed to trade
with
other British lands.
Okay? So, the Americans can trade with
England and with India,
but they're not allowed to trade with
the French, and the Dutch, and the
Spanish. And the Americans don't really
like this either, okay? So, these are
the three main factors driving division
between the American colonists and the
British Crown. And this will, of course,
culminate in the American Revolution,
okay? The War of Independence of 1776.
Also, what's really important for us to
remember at this time is that per
capita, the Americans are far wealthier
than the British.
Okay? Now, this is strange. And you ask
yourself, why is it that even though
England is industrializing far more
rapidly than the Americans, and there
are more
uh British citizens than than Americans,
and also Britain is an empire, whereas
America is a colony, how is it
that the Americans per capita are able
to become wealthier
than
the British? And the answer has to do
with the American work ethic, the
American attitude towards life. And this
is best expressed by a man named
Benjamin Franklin. Okay, who is
considered one of the founding fathers
of America. He is um he he had an
incredible life. He was born poor, but
through hard work, through tenacity,
through optimism, um he was able to
become a merchant, a very wealthy
merchant, and an inventor, a
philosopher, an ambassador, a
politician, okay? So, he is basically
the role model for Americans. Towards
the end of his life, he wrote his
autobiography.
And so, we're going to study his
autobiography in order to get insight
into the mentality
of the average American at this stage in
history, okay?
Now,
Benjamin Franklin, by writing by writing
his memoir, he starts a new fad in
America that persists today. It's called
the self-improvement or self-help uh
fad. And And these are the best These
are the books that sell the most in
America. So, you may have heard of How
to Win Friends and Influence People by
Dale Carnegie. There's also Napoleon
Hill, Think and Grow Rich, okay? And
these books are just telling you how to,
as as as they say, how to be more
successful in life, okay? This is called
the self-help movement. And Americans
really pioneered this. Before in
history,
no one believed that through your hard
work, you can actually attain more in
life. And in fact, you must uh go up and
obtain more in life, okay? So, the
Americans really start this self-help
uh fad. All right.
So, let's read certain passages from the
autobiography of Benjamin Franklin to
gain insight into the American
psychology, okay?
From the bosom of poverty and obscurity,
so he was born poor and was born a
nobody.
In which I drew my first breath and
spent my earliest years, I've raised
myself to a state of opulence and to
some degree of celebrity in the world.
This is the American dream. You can be
born poor, but through hard work, you
can become rich, okay?
A constant good fortune has tended me
through every period of life to my
present advanced age. And my descendants
may be desirous of learning what were
the means of which I made use and which,
thanks to the assisting hand of
Providence, have proved so eminently
successful. They may also, should they
ever be placed in a similar situation,
derive some advantages from my
narrative, okay? So, not only is going
to tell you how he will how he became
rich, but he will teach you how to
become rich, okay? So, if you just do
what he does, you'll become rich as
well. So, this is the American optimism.
This is the American dream.
All right.
So, he continues.
He's talking to a friend and his friend
tells him,
"Your writing sucks."
And at this time,
he should be angry, right? But instead,
he recognizes that
look, there's merit in my friend's
criticism. So, So, I will improve
myself, okay?
Um and the way he improves himself and
he and he writes it, I won't read it
because it's too long. But what he what
he does is this.
He takes a magazine, The Spectator,
which is very well written,
and then he summarizes the main points
of the articles that he's read. Then he
will take the summary and he will
rewrite the article from memory himself.
And then he will compare and contrast
his work with that of the original work,
and then he will make adjustments and
refinements to his own writing, okay?
Now, um if you if you actually know how
to write and if I if you actually met
good writers, writers don't write like
this, okay? This is not how you learn
how to read and write. But again, this
shows us the optimism
of the American character.
That through just pure hard work and
tenacity and persistent, you can learn
anything. Even though um historically we
all know that writers are people of
genius, they're sort of born great
writers.
Okay? You're not going to learn how to
be a man of genius just through pure
imitation, okay? But what he's telling
us that No, it's it's like No, through
imitation, you can improve yourself.
Okay? That's a very American outlook.
All right.
Now, he's going to tell us how he became
rich.
I began to pay by degrees the debt I had
contracted. And in order to ensure my
credit and character as a tradesman, I
took care not only to be really
industrious and frugal, but also to
avoid every appearance
of the contrary.
I was plainly dressed and never seen any
place of public amusement, okay? So,
this is This he's telling you how he
became rich. First of all, he was
honest. When he did business, he made
sure that he never tricked anyone, okay?
His reputation mattered above all.
Also, he dressed in a very simple way.
He didn't waste any money. He He came
across to everyone as someone who was a
good Christian, a good Calvinist,
someone who enjoyed making money and
someone who saved all his money
uh in pursuit of the praise of God,
okay? And this is how you become rich in
America.
Right? And you can imagine that um
there is merit to what he says, that if
you do work hard, if you are honest, and
if you save a lot of money, then it's
possible for you to become rich.
Okay? And this is the common mentality
right now at this stage in America.
Okay, he continues.
I have related that during the autumn of
the preceding year, I united the
majority of well-informed persons of my
acquaintance into a club, which we
called by the name of the Junto, and
then object of which was to improve our
understandings. Okay, this is really
important. What he's telling us that
after he became rich, he met other rich
people and they formed a philosophy club
to debate and discuss the political
issues of the day. It was like a It was
like a book club.
Okay? They read John Locke, um they read
Thomas Hobbes and and they discussed
these ideas. So, this is a
quintessential American attitude.
Constant self-improvement.
Okay? You You You can become the
wealthiest man in the world, but you
still must read books.
Also, this is important because these
book clubs will become the foundation of
the American Revolution, right?
These founding fathers will meet in
these clubs and they will conspire to
seek independence from the United from
Britain. A lot of A lot of it is
they believe that providence, God, has
tasked them with founding a new nation
based on enlightenment principles. So,
the religion of these people is what we
call deism, okay? Uh d e i s m.
And the idea of deism, that's very
different from previous religions, is
they believe there is a God and God
created the universe, but after that,
God went away. And now it is
responsibility of humans to make the
world perfect.
Okay? That's the mission from God.
All right.
This was the best school for politics
and philosophy that then existed in the
province. For our questions, which were
read once a week previous to the
discussion, induced us to peruse
attentively such books as were written
upon the subject proposed that we might
be able to speak upon them more
permanently. Okay? So, they know that
Providence has tasked them with creating
a great nation called America. And to
understand how to do so, they will read
all the books of integrity. They will
study Rome. They will study Athens,
Sparta, Carthage. They will study the
Dutch Republic. They will study the
British Constitution. Okay? And by
studying these these
um
um classics, they will come to a
consensus on how to build a new society
um in the image of God. Okay? Does that
make sense?
Okay? This is the foundation of the
American Revolution.
All right. So, um not only did America
become very wealthy very fast through
the hard work, simplicity, and optimism
of the people, but as you can see from
this map, they basically spread out
really quickly. At this time in history,
the Spanish, the British, the French are
all in North America. The Russians are
here as well, but over time, the
Americans will push everyone out. And
this is what what they call Manifest
Destiny. Okay?
All right. So, 1776,
America declare declares independence
from Britain. And again, this is this is
after years and years of conflict uh
over a myriad of issues. Thomas
Jefferson,
the one of the Founding Fathers, he
writes something called the Declaration
of Independence. Why is America
declaring independence from Britain? And
the answer is,
"We hold these truths to be
self-evident, that all men are created
equal, that they are endowed by the
Creator with certain unalienable rights,
that among these are life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness. That to secure
these rights, governments are instituted
among men, deriving their just powers
from the consent of the governed, that
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends, it is the
right of the people to alter or to
abolish it. Okay, guys,
Thomas Jefferson, in writing the
Declaration of Independence, which is
the founding document of the United
States, he is just copying word for
word, basically, John Locke spoke the
Second Treatises of Government. Okay,
this is what John Locke said. We are
born with three fundamental rights that
God has given us therefore no one can
take away from us. The right to life,
liberty, and the pursuit of property.
Government is instituted, created, in
order to protect our rights. If a
government fails to protect these
rights, then we have a responsibility
and a right to abolish this government
and create a new one.
Okay?
All right. So, there's the War of
Independence, and the great hero of this
war, of course, is George Washington.
Why Americans revere
So, so can you open the door? Why
Americans revere George Washington is
that it's not how great he was during
the war,
um because ultimately the Americans
didn't actually defeat the British. It
was the French, the Spanish who combined
together to defeat the British. Um and
eventually the British decided that, you
know what,
the Americans call colonists are they're
too much prob-
they're too problematic. We don't really
care, okay? So, let's just focus on
Europe. So, um the Americans fought a
guerrilla warfare, and they were very
brave, but without the French, the uh
the Americans could not possibly have
defeated the British, okay? So, but what
made George Washington so esteemed
uh in the hearts of the American people
is after this war, he retired, okay? He
just went back to his farm and enjoyed
uh his last years in the garden. And
that's why Americans worship him because
he's a man who could have become king of
America, but instead he chose to
um grant Americans their freedom and
independence, okay?
Um
the aide-de-camp of George Washington,
the genius of American Revolution, is
actually Alexander Hamilton. He is the
really the founder of America. He's
really the one who has the vision of
what of where America could go, of where
what America could be, okay? His name is
Alexander Hamilton.
And he is in conflict with Jefferson.
These two individuals represent two
competing uh strands of America after uh
the War of Independence.
For
Thomas Jefferson
what's important is to maintain
the inalienable individual rights of the
individuals. He wants a democracy. And
because most people are farmers at this
point um
he believes economic policies should be
focused on agriculture, okay? So, this
is a Thomas Jefferson Thomas Jefferson
uh ideals of American Revolution.
Hamilton saw the world differently. He
believed in his heart, as did many
people at this time, America is destined
to be a empire and therefore it needs a
strong central government.
And in order to become an empire, it
must have industry, okay?
So, um some certain points. Um so
the colonists are fighting the British
for because
uh the British are trying to tax them,
the British are trying to impose an army
on them, and because the British are
trying to to limit their trade.
Okay? So, in order to get everyone to
fight, they created something called the
Articles of Confederation,
which limits the power of the government
to impose taxes, which limits the
ability of the government to raise
troops. But, this is problematic
because
you can actually fight a war like this,
okay? So, um after the British leave and
leave America alone, problems start to
arise.
Basically, the main problem is you have
lots and lots of soldiers who used to be
farmers. They were promised pay when
they joined the militia against the
British, but because the government has
no money,
they had no money, okay? And they're
also farmers, and because they had to
leave their farms, they fell into debt.
And so, rich people came and took took
took over their farms. And this led to
something called the Shay's Rebellion,
where farmers are now trying to
overthrow the government.
And so,
the solution was to create something
called the Constitution, which would
grant
more power to the central government,
especially to
um
collect revenue, to control trade,
foreign trade, and to have a army,
basically, okay? So, that was that was
the solution uh that proposed by
Hamilton and his friends. Jefferson
argued that this would, of course, limit
the rights of individuals. So, he
insisted on adding something called the
Bill of Rights to the Constitution,
okay? You may have heard something
called the First Amendment, the Second
Amendment, uh the right to speak freely,
the right to bear arms. This is a This
is from the Bill of Rights. It's
actually not in the Constitution. The
Constitution is a framework for how to
build a strong central government, okay?
Second thing I want you guys to
um
um understand is
agriculture and industry, it's a it's a
different
framework, okay? It's a different
economic framework. With agriculture,
you You a lot of slave labor because
obviously
you need people to
uh um man the fields and grow the crops,
okay? And that's why
if you want to have agriculture, you
have to you have to bring actually a lot
of slave labor from Africa.
But if you focus on industry, you don't
want slave labor. You want free labor,
okay? You want the market to decide who
does what job and how much they get
paid. This is a much more efficient way
to organize your economy if you are
industrializing. And the reason why is
when you're industrializing, you need
specialized labor.
Okay? You need differentiation of
skills. And the market is the best
mechanism for
skills to be differentiated and to be
rewarded.
Okay? Also, think about this.
If you got really sick, okay? You You
need heart surgery. Would you rather go
to a doctor
um who's a slave or a doctor who's going
to charge you a million dollars?
Right? So, um free labor just allows for
more economic activity and therefore
more wealth generation in society.
All right? So, these are two competing
visions of where America should be
headed. And of course, this is a
contradiction, okay? You can't have
slave labor and free labor at the same
time. The North goes uh in in in its
policy of free labor. The South
maintains policy of slave labor because
they were mainly an agricultural
uh
uh society. Ob- obviously, Jefferson is
from the South. Hamilton is from New
York.
This conflict would eventually give rise
to the American Civil War of 1861, okay?
So, this conflict has always been there.
But in 1789, when they introduced the
Constitution, they chose to ignore this
conflict until 1861 when this conflict
finally led to violence, okay? So, this
is the root of the American Civil War.
Does Does that make sense, guys?
All right.
Okay.
Now, let's look at the Constitution. The
Constitution is meant to be the most
perfect form of government ever
established.
Okay? America is a clean slate. It's a
tabula rasa.
Americans can do what they can do
whatever they want. So, they study all
the previous Republican,
Democratic, monarchal, aristocratic
systems and they decide to
imitate
Montesquieu. Montesquieu is a French
thinker who put in the idea of
separation of powers. If you want to
create a perfect government, you need to
have you need to balance the different
factions of society using separation of
powers. Okay? So, the American system is
you have three different branches of
government. You have the president who
controls
um
the military as for as well as foreign
policy.
Then you have the Congress which
controls the purse, the financing of
government. Then you have the Supreme
Court which
um interprets the Constitution, which
interprets the highest law of the land.
And so, if done properly, what will
happen is
these three branches of government will
balance each other out. They make the
checks and balances, okay?
They each is meant to inhibit the
overextension of the other.
That is the American system of
government that is basically stolen from
Montesquieu. All right.
The other uh check check and balance is
the relation between federal, Washington
D.C., the state level, the individual
states, and the local level. Okay? So,
the responsibilities of each is defined
very clearly. And
the idea is that um they should also
balance each other out.
Okay?
This contrasts, of course, with the
Chinese system where you just have one
uh person in charge and he has something
called the Politburo underneath him. The
Politburo then then appoints everyone
into the
um government as well as the army as
well as the provincial and local
governments, okay? So, it's a very
top-down system, whereas the American
system is meant to be a balanced system.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
So, the problem now is now that you've
decided that you need a constitution,
you need a federal government. How do
you convince the people to go along with
this? Because for the constitution to go
into effect, all 13 states have to agree
to the constitution by a 2/3 majority.
Okay? So, to convince people,
um Alexander Hamilton, James Madison,
and John Jay write something called The
Federalist Papers. The Federalist Papers
are a series of pamphlets, series of
newspaper articles that explain
why the constitution is necessary.
Okay? So, let's um So, we're we're going
to look at a few passages. All of them
are written by Alexander Hamilton, who
is really again the genius of the
constitution, the one who is really
driving the need for a strong central
government in order to facilitate
America's imperial ambitions.
All right.
As this government is composed of small
republics and enjoys internal happiness
of each. In respect to its external
situation, it is possessed by means of
the association of all the advantages of
large monarchies. Okay? So, this idea of
a mixed balanced government, where you
are trying to take advantage advantage
of all political systems.
Within America, it will be a republican
system.
Okay? And so, you will enjoy within your
area democracy.
But at a national level, in relation to
other states, it'll be a monarchy where
the president represents the nation in
discussions and negotiations and
conflicts with the other great European
nations.
Okay?
All right.
Another um thing that the uh
Constitution does is if the president
wants to appoint ministers, if the
government if the president wants to
appoint officials, they have to be
vetted
and approved by the Senate.
Okay? And this is this is new.
Uh usually a king can appoint who
whoever he or she wants.
But in the Constitution, the Senate must
vet everyone. And the idea of this is to
create accountability and transparency
within government.
Okay? So, Hamilton explains this.
To what purpose then require the
cooperation of the Senate? I answer that
a necessity of their concurrence would
have a powerful, though in general a
sound operation. It would be an
excellent check upon a spirit of
favoritism in the president and would
tend greatly to prevent the appointment
of unfit characters from state
prejudice, from family connection, from
personal attachment, or from a view to
popularity. Okay, let's just say the
president wants to appoint his son to be
the Secretary of State. Okay? The son
appears before the Senate and it is like
a job interview. And then the son is an
idiot. He doesn't know anything, okay?
So, in this instance, the son has
embarrassed the president. And it's this
fear of being embarrassed
that inhibits
the president from abusing his powers.
Okay? That's the theory, okay? Does that
make sense? And and over actually over
the course of American history, it's
worked very, very well, okay? The power
of public opinion, it's very, very
strong. But what's important for us to
remember is
all this is based on the idea of
convention, on norms, on values. As long
as people buy into these conventions and
norms, this system will work. But if you
have someone like Donald Trump
who does not buy into these norms and
values, it may be a problem, okay?
Okay? So, we'll see what happens in the
next few years.
All right.
These judicious reflections contain a
lesson of moderation to all the sincere
lovers of the Union and ought to put
them upon their guard against hazarding
anarchy, civil war, or perpetual
alienation of the states from each
other, and perhaps the military
despotism of victorious demagogue. Okay,
let me explain what this means. What
this is saying is this,
Alexander Hamilton, what he's saying is
this, in creating a government, we're
not we're not trying to aspire to
greatness. We're trying to prevent
collapse. This is risk management. We're
trying to avoid the risk of government,
okay? What's the risk of government?
Well, you could have anarchy, where
people reject the government. You have
civil war, where the states go to war
against each other. You could have a
perpetual alienation of the states from
each other, division within the
government, and then military despotism,
where tyrant arises, okay? So, that's
the point of the Constitution, it's risk
management. It's to prevent America from
failing.
All right?
All right.
So, um after the Constitution, America
uh now embarks on something called
Manifest Destiny. What they did Manifest
Destiny is, it's the will of God for
America to conquer and settle the entire
Western Hemisphere.
Okay? North America, South America, it's
all America because that is the will of
God.
So, today Trump is saying how America
should annex Canada and as well as
Greenland. That's part of Manifest
Destiny. It's not new.
All right?
All right.
This leads to 1823, something called the
Monroe Doctrine. So, President Monroe,
um before Congress, he announces that
from now on, the Europeans are not
allowed to interfere
in the Western Hemisphere. The Western
Hemisphere is entirely American.
Okay? So, he says,
"Europe are henceforth not to be
considered as subjects for future
colonization by any European powers.
The Western Hemisphere is henceforth not
to be considered as subjects for future
colonization by any European powers. Hey
guys, Russia, France, Germany, Britain,
Spain, forget the Western Hemisphere,
it's our territory. You come over here
and we'll beat the crap out of you,
okay?"
All right. So, um
now America, to achieve its manifest
destiny, it needs to expand, okay? And
it uses multiple strategies to expand.
In 1803, remember the mid- west of the
United States is controlled by France.
It basically buys all this from
Napoleon.
Okay? So, now it's extending outwards
over to here. Of course, there are there
are natives in these territories. What
Americans do, of course, is eradicate
the the natives. It's a war of genocide.
All right. Um War of 1812 is when
America and Canada come into conflict.
Again, because of manifest destiny,
America sees Canada as part of uh of its
territory, but the British don't agree
and this leads to the War of 1812. It's
a stalemate, okay? And after stalemate,
basically the British and Americans
agree that Canada will stay a British
um colony, but
uh again, because of manifest destiny,
we can expect America to eventually take
over Canada as well as Greenland.
Um 1846, the Mexican-American War. So,
America fights a war with Mexico and
takes over Texas as well as California,
okay? Basically, the entire western part
of the United States is now incorporated
into
uh the new nation.
Um this In 1861, we have the Civil War,
all right? And I've already explained
the causes of the Civil War, right? This
conflict between Thomas Jefferson and
Hamilton. The two visions for where
America is going will eventually lead us
to the American Civil War. You may have
learned that the American Civil War was
about slavery. It was not about slavery.
It was mainly about state rights. Okay?
It was really about democracy versus
empire. In a democracy the states can do
whatever they want. But in an empire the
central government is able to dictate a
lot of policy, okay? So eventually this
will lead to
the Civil War. And of course the North
wins the Civil War because the North is
um far more industrial, far more
wealthier and powerful than the South.
And and so the Hamilton vision is now
achieved and it will it will be expanded
throughout the Western Hemisphere.
There's a problem though. The problem is
this.
Um so at this time of course Abraham
Lincoln is president of the United
States and he's considered the greatest
president in American history for a
reason. The reason is this. The Civil
War was the deadliest war in American
history, okay? Let's Let's look at this.
Over 600,000 people died in the American
Civil War which was about 4 years.
Um
only 400,000 died in World War II.
Right?
The problem is this. In 1861 the
population of America at this time was
30 million people.
World War II the population was 130
million. So this was by far the
deadliest war in American history.
Brothers were killing brothers. It was a
tremendous um
um there I mean it was such a bloody
conflict. And so after this war was
ended
everyone was asking, "Why did we do
this?
What's the point of this?" And so there
was shock,
um there was anger, there was
frustration. So Abraham Lincoln now has
to stand up and explain why this
happened. Why did this war happen?
All right? He needs to form a new vision
of America that binds people together,
that creates a new union. Okay? So, he
presents this new vision in something
called the Gettysburg Address, which is
considered the greatest speech in
American history. Okay, this is 1863. Um
the Battle of Gettysburg was one of the
bloodiest war bloodiest battles in the
American Civil War. And he And I'm we're
going to read all of it, okay? It's
because it's a very short speech and
it's very powerful.
Fourscore and seven years seven years
ago our fathers brought forth on this
continent a new nation, conceived in
liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal.
All right. So, the war of independence,
it was not a war
to seek independence from Britain. It
was a revolution in human affairs.
It was about bringing liberty to the
world. Okay, it was about creating a new
civilization.
Now we are engaged in a great civil war,
testing whether that nation, or any
nation so conceived and so dedicated,
can long endure.
Okay? So, the American Revolution, it is
an experiment in the possibilities of
human liberation. And the Civil War, it
is meant to destroy this experiment. So,
we must persist in this experiment.
We are met on a great battlefield of
that war, Gettysburg. We have come to
dedicate a portion of that field as a
final resting place for those who here
gave their lives that the nation might
live.
It is altogether fitting and proper that
we should do this.
Okay.
But in a larger sense, we cannot
dedicate, we cannot consecrate, we
cannot hollow this ground. The sacrifice
of the men is what has made this land
sacred. The sacrifice of these of these
men is what made our nation um
is what makes our nation sacred. It's
what saves our nation.
The brave men, living and dead, who
struggled here have consecrated it far
above our poor power to add or detract.
The world will little note, nor long
remember what we say here, but it can
never forget what they did here. It is
for us the living rather to be dedicated
here to the unfinished work which they
who fought here have thus far so nobly
advanced.
Okay? And this ends it.
It is rather for us to be here dedicated
to the great task remaining before us
that from these honored dead we take
increased devotion to the cause for
which they here gave the last full
measure of devotion. The men are dead.
There's nothing we can do to resurrect
them. It is our responsibility of us the
living to honor the sacrifice
and to continue the mission that they
died for, which is spread liberty
throughout the world, to bring liberty
into human civilization.
That we here highly resolve that these
dead shall not have died in vain, that
this nation under God shall have a new
birth of freedom, and that government of
the people, by the people, for the
people shall not perish from the earth.
Okay?
So, the So, again, with Hamilton it's
about empire, for Jefferson it's about
democracy. There's a conflict, right?
What Lincoln does, which is revolution,
is say, "No, this is not a conflict
because we are an empire of democracy."
We are born in liberty, we fight for
liberty, and we will spread liberty.
All right? So, this is a new concept in
American history. Not only Not So, now
America is not confined to the Western
Hemisphere.
It has responsibility to honor the dead,
honor sacrifice by creating liberty
throughout the world, to create a new
chapter in human civilization. Okay?
That's the purpose of this speech.
To heal America by reminding them of
their divine mission to spread democracy
and truth throughout the world. All
right. So, after the Civil War, America
is now industrializing rapidly.
1867, it buys Alaska from Russia.
Um 1898, America fights the Spanish
and they take over the Spanish colonies.
So, now America has become an imperial
power. All right? America now controls
the Philippines as well as Cuba.
Then,
um World War I,
America goes and defeats Germany.
World War II is when America becomes
um
the global hegemon of the world.
And then after the Soviet Union fell,
uh we now live in something called the
Pax Americana. Okay? America is the
greatest power in the world. They have
complete Lincoln's vision of becoming an
empire of democracy. We now live in the
empire of democracy.
All right? But the question then is,
what is an empire of democracy? What is
that? And so, we go back to Oscar
Wilde's quote.
America is not a civilization.
All right? And what does he mean by
that?
To understand this, we have to read
another book called Democracy in America
by a French man named Alexis de
Tocqueville. This is the most famous
book ever written about America.
Okay? Not by an American, but by a
French man who visited America for maybe
8 months. In 1835, he publishes
Democracy in America.
And he's trying to explain why is it
that American democracy works? And why
is it And why is it destined to
eventually conquer the world?
All right. Um
now, there's a lot of debate about this
book. Uh hopefully you'll be able to
read this book um,
in college. It is a fantastic book. It's
really one of the best books ever
written.
Um, and it's a thousand pages. So, it's
possible for you to interpret the book
in many different ways.
But, what I want to show you today is
Alexis de Tocqueville actually is
skeptical about American democracy.
He is actually,
um, afraid of what the spreading of
American liberty will mean for the
world, okay? So, the argument I will
show you is
America is really the first mass
democratic middle class country, okay?
But, because of that, the people there
are selfish, conformist, and
unimaginative.
And he fears that as America conquers
the world,
the world will become atomized, uniform,
and mediocre.
Atomized just means that we live in our
own little bubble. We don't really care
about larger issues than than ourselves.
Uh, uniform means everyone thinks the
same way. And mediocre means that, well,
no one's striving for greatness anymore.
If you think about it, okay? The world
we live in today, in the year 2025,
this is the world we live in.
It's a atomized, uniform, and mediocre
world. So, how did this happen?
How was it possible for the world to
become like this?
And for for For you to understand this,
it's important to go back to the Dutch
Republic. We discussed the Dutch
Republic last week and talk about what
it means to be middle class. Now, as I
said last week, the middle class is
distinct because it creates anxiety,
uncertainty, and competition within the
lives of individuals. Okay? Anxiety
comes from the fact that your situation
is never stable. You could be rich
tomorrow, but you could be poor
the next day. This is different from
history where if you're born poor, you
stay poor. If you're a noble person, it
you could have no money, but your Your
stays with you, okay? And it goes passes
on to your children and your
grandchildren, okay? So, So, there's a
certainty in that world.
Um but in this world, if you're a middle
class,
you could be a factory owner, you could
be Jack Ma, and then the next day you
get unlucky and you lose all your money,
okay? And you're back to being a poor
person. This creates anxiety and
uncertainty. Also, because
um
status is not given, but it must be
earned, there's competition among middle
class members to strive for status,
okay? And this creates something we call
OCD, obsessive-compulsive disorder, and
it leads to an obsessive control of
yourself, uh
a focus on cleanliness, and a desire to
accumulate and achieve, okay? And if you
think about it, we discussed the
the memoir of Benjamin Franklin, right?
Well, why is he focused on such a simple
living?
Why is he focused on earning so much
money? Why does he constantly want to
achieve? It's because of the anxiety
of being middle class. You're born poor,
you get you you you earn a lot of money,
you become wealthy, but how do you know
you won't become poor? How do you know
your children won't become poor? The
only only way to resolve this anxiety is
by constantly accumulating more and
more.
Okay?
All right.
So, let's
um
look at Democracy in America, okay?
Let's look at certain passages in about
um let's look at certain passages from
Democracy in America to understand the
thinking of de Tocqueville. All right.
Such a democratic society would be less
brilliant than the arist- aristocracy,
but also less plagued by misery.
Pleasures would be less extreme,
prosperity more general, knowledge would
be less exalted, but ignorance more
rare. Feelings would be less passionate
and habits milder. There would be more
vices and fewer crimes. Okay, this is
actually a hard passage to understand.
So, what he's is is this,
in aristocratic aristocratic societies,
in most societies, there's a huge gap
between the rich and the poor, okay?
And there's a huge gap between the great
and the mediocre.
What democratic societies do is they
take this system and they turn it into
this system, okay? So, the middle class
um they're not that great, but they're
not that poor, either, okay? They're not
as talented, but they're not as
mediocre, okay? So, you've you've taken
this system, right? And you turn it into
this system, and that's the theory of
democracy. And in theory, this sounds
better, okay? If you you If you're just
born
uh randomly into a democratic democratic
society, you're much more likely to live
a happy life than if you were born into
an aristocratic society, okay? So,
that's the theory.
But,
de Tocqueville spent a lot of time
looking at America, and he and he
decided that's not what happened, okay?
It's not like you went from this to
this. It's like you went from this to
like this, okay?
All right. So, he explains,
"But, what have we done? In rejecting
the social state our ancestors and
casting aside the institutions, ideas,
and mores, what have we put in their
place?" So, what he's saying is the
American Revolution was about destroying
tradition, about destroying
civilization, but they failed to build
new traditions and new civilization.
"The prestige of world power has
evaporated, but the majesty of the law
has failed to take its place." Okay,
this is key.
Um before, we worshiped a man, a king,
and the king made us
um obedient to his law.
We got rid of the king, and we said,
"Well, uh let's keep the law." The
problem is this. The problem is
people respect and revere those who are
superior
to them. They do not respect and revere
ideas and things and laws. Does that
make sense?
Okay?
So, in theory, America is rule of law
nation, but
people don't really understand these
laws and people don't revere these laws
as much as they would a superior man.
It strikes me that we have destroyed
those individuals who once had the whip
of all to battle tyranny on their own.
So, in a aristocratic system,
what will happen is you would
is you have these great individuals like
Robespierre emerge to challenge the
system and he feels um and he's
supported by others because others see
the injustice of the system. But, in a
democracy, what happens is great
individuals are oppressed by the
conformity, the tyranny of the majority.
Okay, does that make sense?
Right? If everyone's happy, then you say
and but if you come out and say,
"Listen, this system is wrong." People
will shut you down.
Right? In an aristocracy, everyone knows
what's unjust. So, if you come out and
you say speak speak what's unjust,
people will follow you. But, in a
democracy, in middle middle-class
society,
which is conformist, you're you're not
allowed to question popular opinion.
And therefore, no great men can arise.
If you think about it, in American
history,
there aren't that many great
individuals.
Okay? It's a great country. It's very
wealthy.
Um but, think about how many great
individuals who have arisen. What's also
unique about America is the people they
worship are not generals, not leaders,
but business people. Henry Ford, Elon
Musk,
Thomas Edison, right? These are all
business people. That's who they
worship.
The poor man, for the most part, clings
to his forebears' prejudices without
their faith and to their ignorance
without their virtues.
Okay. So, the Catholic Church was
problematic, medieval Europe was
problematic, but at least people knew
how to live a good life.
Now, if you're poor person, you're a
complete loss in the system.
Okay, you're expected to have your own
virtues. You're expected to discover
your own purpose in life.
But,
if you don't, then you're alienated,
okay? And this creates a huge problem
uh that we'll discuss later on.
All right, he continues. "I see men who
in the name of progress seek to reduce
men to material being. This is the
ultimate problem in America. Before in
civilization, you were asked to die for
your nation.
Now, you're asked to go make money and
buy things.
Okay? Materialism.
They look for what is useful without
concern for what is just. They seek
science removed from faith and
prosperity apart from virtue. Having
styled themselves of modern
civilization, they have arrogantly
placed themselves at its head, usurping
a position abandoned by others which
they are quite
Okay, so in this system, the worst rise
to power.
The best are trampled down by
conformity.
All right.
All right. He continues. "I'm trying to
imagine what new features despotism
might have in today's world. I see an
innumerable host of men all alike and
equal, endlessly hastening after petty
and vulgar pleasures with which they
fill their souls. Over these men stand
an immense tutelary power which assumes
sole responsibility for securing the
pleasures and watching over their fate."
Think about the society that we live in
today, the entire world. Before, we were
asked to sacrifice ourselves for
civilization. Before, we were asked to
um be great, to work together. Now,
we're asked to just buy things. Buying
things will make us happy.
And it's responsibility of the
government to ensure we can buy things,
okay?
That's the world we live in today.
It's It's impossible to believe that a
liberal, energetic, and wise government
can ever emerge from about our nation of
servants. If you're a consumer, if all
you concern is buying things, you are
just a slave.
The possibility of a constitution being
republican in its head and also
monarchical in all of its other parts
has always struck me as an infernal
monster. Okay, we think we live in a
democracy. We think the government
listens to us, but it's really the
imperial bureaucracy that's in charge.
And that's a monster.
The vice of those who govern and the
imbecility of the governed would quickly
bring about its ruin, and the people,
tired of their representatives and of
themselves, would either create free
institutions or soon return to
prostrating themselves at the feet at
the feet of a single master.
Okay, so this is a prophecy. The
prophecy is this, America
the way it is structured, the way it is
conceived, is not sustainable in the
long term. Either it will break apart in
a civil war or a tyrant will emerge.
It will become a monarchy. Okay, that is
De Tocqueville's dark prophecy for
America.
Okay.
So, um
America is again in competition with
these other civilizations.
All right, so what I will do now is just
summarize what we've learned to give you
a broad framework for understanding the
nature of American society, okay?
I'm sorry.
All right.
So So, I I apologize. I
I I know that today was very fast.
Um but let me just summarize what we've
learned and you'll have a much clearer
idea
um of
the ideas today. All right.
So, before
the focus on civilization. What is
civilization? It is a history
culture
values. Okay? And before everyone
understood the purpose of your life was
to maintain, protect, and defend your
civilization.
Okay? But there's there's certain
problems with civilization that emerges
over time. The first, of course, is the
idea of prejudice.
You just believe that you your
civilization is superior to that of
other civilizations. Okay? Everyone
believes this.
Um my civilization is better and I would
and I my civilization is superior to
yours. So, this leads This is prejudice.
It leads to war
violence. It leads to
um lack of innovation, openness.
Right?
It's a stubbornness, inflexibility.
It also limits immigration.
Okay?
Does that make sense? Okay? This is the
nature of civilization throughout most
of human history.
Now, this is a problem for America. Why?
Because as I mentioned, America was
founded by
immigrants.
Right? It's was It was It's also pretty
diverse.
Diversity, openness.
And
um so,
these are the three characteristics of
America. It's a very diverse place with
different religions, different cultures.
It's always going to welcome immigrants
in order to build up its nation and
wealth. And it has to be open because it
needs to steal ideas from Europe,
basically. All right? So, now you have a
problem.
Right? Civilization cannot solve these
problems.
So, what do you do in order to create a
society? What you do is rather than
build a civilization, you create a game.
Okay? In many ways, America is an
anti-civilization. It's trying to remedy
the failings and weaknesses of
civilizations in the past.
It decided, "We're going to create a
game, guys. Okay?" That's the idea of
the US Constitution.
What's the game? The game is this.
First of all, we need to have game
masters. Game masters is the government.
And but the problem is
for the game to work, it has to be fair.
It has to be clean.
Okay? It has to be winnable for people.
Does that make sense? You only play
games if you think the game is fair and
it's winnable and it's rewarding, right?
It's transparent. Therefore, our
government must be fair,
transparent, and democratic. You got as
many people to play the game as
possible.
All right? Once the government is in
place, now what we do is
we create the rules for the game that
are
um fair, just, and which is winnable,
okay? So,
the purpose of this game is to make as
much money as possible, okay? Material
acquisition.
If you win this money, it's yours, okay?
Private property.
By law, whatever you earn, whatever you
whatever you have earned is yours
forever. It's yours It's yours, but it's
also your children's, okay?
Do you understand? This is a game that
America has constructed.
If you think about it, this is great
because now you can bring in as many
immigrants as you want. Because all they
do is play this game. Everyone wants to
play this game.
It allows you to be open because it
allows for rapid innovation within your
society.
Okay, it allows for diversity as well
because everyone's striving to make as
much money as possible.
Okay?
So, that's what America is. America
sees itself as a new civilization, but
it's really an anti-civilization because
it's really a game.
And over time what happened is because
America is becoming more and more
wealthy, it will be able to conquer the
world and establish the game throughout
the world.
In China today,
we are playing this game, right?
What What do we believe? We believe that
we come to school
because we need to get an education, go
to America, get a degree so that we can
become rich. When we become rich, we can
buy things, right?
We're playing this game.
We've all been brainwashed
to play this game.
Okay?
The problem with this game is eventually
the few
will win everything. Does that make
sense? You have massive inequality
in the world.
And when this happens,
people are like, "This game sucks.
What do we do now?"
And then
people will be like, "You know what?
I miss civilization. I miss when it was
clear what my identity was. When it was
clear what I had to do in life. When I
was asked to make sacrifices for the
greater good.
I miss that. I'm nostalgic for that,
okay?
And of course, this is what gives us
MAGA.
Right?
Ultimately, MAGA is about trying to
restore the idea of civilization in
America.
Make America great again. Make America
into a white Christian
democratic nation again. Let us restore
the vision of Thomas Jefferson.
All right?
Okay. That's it. So, this is just an
introduction to America. We'll continue
this topic as we move further and
further along the course, okay? So, next
week we will do
um the German and Russian civilizations.
What you will see is that in many ways
these civilizations are far superior to
the Anglo-American empire.
All right?
So, any questions?
Okay.